[Musique]
l'arboretum nationale des bars l'une des
plus riches collections botaniques
européenne
plus de 2600 espèces d'arbres ou
d'arbustes issus des cinq continents à
découvrir par soi-même ou accompagné
aujourd'hui nous suivons mari on part
pour une visite qui s'appelle nom de nom
donc on va essayer de découvrir les
arbres avec leurs rangs non latins et
non français il y a toute une histoire
derrière ces mots latins pas si
compliqué que cela à comprendre quand on
nous donne les clés au fil de la visite
notre guide décrypte raconte et
illustrent chacun de ces propos un fruit
une image une musique le dialogue
s'installe on essaye de pouvoir faire
une visite interactive et d'avoir
beaucoup d' approche différente
et puis de relier cet arboretum à
l'histoire convient tout ce qu'on a vécu
et qu'on va vivre demain quel est
l'instrument musique y a pas de piège de
traversier mais moi je connais bien le
site puisque j'y travaille
mais confinement oblige marges et un peu
rapatriés ma famille pour dire on va
profiter du coin sans prendre de risque
par rapport aux virus tout va bien et
c'est une météo tellement agréable et on
a des explications qui sont très très
satisfaisant sur les arbres sur les
choses qui nous entourent
là on connaît la nature des arbres la
nature des des choses et c'est toujours
très intéressant
un rendez vous apprécié par les amateurs
comme les initiés ici tout n'est que
luxe calme et volupté
l'arboretum ouvre ses portes plusieurs
week-ends durant l'été
je